ملفات عده ينقسم حولها الامريكيون في
انتخابات التجديد النصفي للكونجرس انقسام
صارخ في الواقع ينعكس على صناديق الاقتراع
استطلاع لصحيفه واشنطن بوستو واي بي سي
نيوز وجد ان الناخبين يرون ان الحسبه
الجمهوري يجيد حل بعض القضايا الشائكه
ويتقدم في الاقتصاد وفي حجم الاقبال
الناخبين بحسب الاستطلاع تنقسم نوايا
الناخبين باقتراع مجلس النواب بالتساوي
بين الحزبين
49% من الناخبين المسجلين قالوا انهم
سيصوطون للمرشح الجمهوري بينما قال 88% من
الناخبين المسجلين انهم سيصوطون للحزب
الديمقراطي اما الناخبون المحتملون
فنقسموا الى 50 بالمئه يميلون نحو التصويت
للجمهوريين وثمانيه واربعين بالمئه يملون
نحو التصويت لديمقراطيه ومع الانتخابات
الحاليه
لحوم توقعات بخساره الحزب الحاكم للاغلبيه
فما هو معتاد لا يصل الحزب المسيطر على
كرسي الرئاسه للاغلبيه في الكونغرس فيما
يحتاج الجمهوريون الى سته مقاعد للوصول
الى الاغلبيه يواجه الديمقراطيون تحديا في
محاوله قلب المعادله ووقف مكاسب منافسهم
الجمهوري لا يمكن الاستطلاعات الراي ان
تحدد بشكل دقيق المقاعد التي قد يخسرها او
يربحها اي من الحسبين لكننا نوايا
الناخبين اوضح من الارقام والتوقعات
الناخبوا الجمهوري لا يزال واثقا من نيته
التصويت لصالح حزبه بنحو 80% بينما يبقى
الناخب الديمقراطي متخبيطا بنحو اربعه 74%
وهو اقل بثمان نقاط عن ما كان عليه عام
اخرى اوسع في المنافسه بين الحزبين
فالناخب الجمهوري مهتم بمتابعه مجريات
الانتخابات عن كتب بنحو 48 بالمئه مقارنه
ب 37 بالمئه للديمقراطيه التشتت الكبير في
اراء الشارع حول قضايا ملحها للجميع انعكس
ايضا على استطلاع اخر اجرته شبكته ام بي
سي نيوز اشار الى ان 90 بالمئه من
الناخبين يفضلون سيطره الجمهوريين على
الكونجرس لضبط ملف الهجره مع 65% يفضلونهم
في ملف الجريمه وستين بالمئه يريدونهم
لتحسين الاقتصاد والوظائف في المقابل هناك
86% يفضلون سيطره الديمقراطيين لملف
المناخ مع 74% لملف الاسلحه كما اختارهم
67% لمواجهه تهديدات الديمقراطيه